good afternoon
that was pretty a good introduction so
that I don't really have much to add to
that but so what you can expect today
from this talk is really understanding
what the modern stream processor or the
stateful stream processor really is
about why it came around and I will also
give quite a bit of detail on how flank
and Flinx approach on implementing a
stateful stream processor a little bit
about me a PMC committer at this Apache
Fling project if you follow the project
I've been working on various topics
within the project for example exactly
one streaming connectors or anything
state related for example evolve ability
of stable streaming applications or
state backends which we would actually
go through quite a bit today software
engineer at America and I worked full
time developing open source for a
Patrick link which is part of what I do
here yes so what we will talk about
today is as I mentioned what is stateful
stream processing and how it has evolved
over time the patchy Flinx take on
stateful stream processing okay
so first of all what exactly is stateful
stream processing we have seen over the
past years quite a few different
frameworks that have came around I'm
starting from hatch storm when I was
before I was working out there a fabrica
as a open-source maintainer I was also a
data engineer and every time I was
maintaining a streaming system which was
based on Apache storm now some also has
some stateful kapap capabilities but at
the time back at the time storm really
was normally people use it as a
stateless stream processor where you
maintain your state in an external
storage to work along with your
stateless streaming pipeline and it was
designed that way without stateful
stream processing in mind at the time
was really because stream processing at
that time was really used or seen more
as the approximate or real-time
lair so in the so called lambda
architecture where we have a real time
lair to generate these in implied
aggregations to show what is the real
time result but those results are
usually just approximate and used as
only to complement batch results and
which I would go into in a sec and then
Kingsborough and then some za is
actually a a breaking point here in the
in this in this history is really
because sums I introduced something
which I'll be talking about today called
stateful stream processing sample stream
processing but this was in my opinion
more lately popular made popular by
Apache flink this project there's other
projects that came after Apache playing
for example Apache apex Apache gear pump
these kind of computing also streaming
frameworks but I'm not saying that
they're not as powerful as good but it's
really just how how much of the
streaming community is using each
project at the moment so to really let
people understand what what staple
stream processing is about this is an
example that I usually give quite a lot
so nowadays would collect data and these
data or continuous data and we collect
them in various different kinds of ways
we could collect them in a queue like
Kafka or we could collect them via a log
any file which is also some form of
collection continuous data but how do we
actually process fees before stateful
stream processes processes actually came
around but usually we do this is so what
we do is we form time boundaries with
between V state between these constants
data which basically means for example
from from 3:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. this
hour the data that I received I make it
into a batch file and format as a batch
file and then I use batch jobs to
process these continuously generated
batch files even though the data is
continuously generated ok so this is how
we in the past what we would
traditionally do and to handle this kind
of data and what these batch jobs are
generated as results is then served
to the to the end use or end service via
another database or whatever to store
the results now this looks sort of okay
but if we consider a very simple thing
we're trying to do is recurrence to
compute this conversion metric of each
hour we want to compute how many times a
conversion of event a to event B has
actually occurred okay so once computers
now using this and using this approach
what we would normally do is okay let's
say a if in the ideal world a and B
happens within always the same time
boundary then things are simple because
we don't really need to carry any
intermediate state to following mass
jobs but in this case if a happens in
this time boundary but B happens in the
next time boundary and what you will
need to do is the first jobs output
needs to carry some intermediate state
as input to the next best job right and
then the second mass job needs to
somehow correct the result or output of
the first batch job so there's a lot of
moving parts in this in this approach
and this is where it kind of gets a bit
funky and it gets even more complicated
if let's say a and B these two events
come out of order which is completely
normal in the real world right so why is
this why do we have so many moving parts
in this scenario the thing is data is
continuously generating and the
computation that we're doing is has a
continuous state that changes as each
event comes in so using a batch scenario
to really treat these computations just
just isn't right right so the ideal way
is really we have this queue we collect
this data with our collectors data with
whatever way we do it and then we have
one long-running computation also called
streaming computation which accumulate
State now what the state really means is
the history of a stream represents is
represented by the state and this state
could really be anything could be as
simple as counters in progress windows
window aggregations if you are familiar
way of streaming you would know the term
windowing aggregations or if you're
using this streaming conversation
through incremental trainer machine
learning model for example the stay
would basically be the parameters of the
currently trained ml model okay now the
most important thing is that state
influences the output right so this is
the essence of state within a state full
string processor there's another notion
of time here that we wouldn't we
wouldn't go into detail here but today
but what this basically means here is
that long-running computation as it is
collecting data it needs to know when
data is complete when data's complete
for example in this scenario when we're
trying to compute a result of 3 p.m. to
4 p.m.
within that we need to know okay I have
received completely received all the
data but I need for this window of his
time Landry okay so this stream
processor needs this notion of time to
know when data is complete and when it
can generate results and that is also
also another hint of why this is
generally not correct because it is hard
so also reason about how do you know by
4:00 p.m. you really all the events that
belong to this bucket or this window has
really been received ever ever at the
server side so so to wrap this part up
it's really a sample stream processing
it's not really about real-time it's not
really being about real-time but it's
more about it's more about a correct
paradigm to handle and process
continuous data and being real-time is
really just natural consequence of it
being a stream processor okay so so much
about a concept part of sample stream
processing now I'm going to go into a
patch of things take on stable stream
processing this is going to cover more
about internal details instead of the
let's say B Apache flame programming API
I'm sure the programming API is
completely accessible on the Apache
flink documents so I would say it's
gonna be a bit a bit of a geeky section
that I hope you all like that okay so
just to start this part what exactly is
a stream processing stream processing is
you write some code and this code runs
is run by the system maintain executed
by the system which runs 24/7 is a long
possession and what it does is basically
it takes one record and there in real
times transform it into a new record so
each input stream the input stream is
basically transformed into an output
stream okay now this tributed stream
processing is you have this in pastrami
ssin it given on some key to say it's a
stream of user events and it is
partitioned by user ID and now each
instance of the distributed computation
is then responsible of a specific key
range of the distributor stream okay now
what stateful stream processing is is in
your code what you would feel like is
you're basically maintaining some local
variables but what these local variables
is really accumulating state of what the
previous events in the stream has shown
so far and then base of a state you
manipulate influence your output so this
is called staple stream processing okay
now back in the old times of how we
usually handle safer stateful stream
processing is is it can it can be
basically captured by this image here so
you have a cupcake you and then you have
sources sinks and sinks goes through
that's a kv store cache and if your
conversation is stateful you would store
the state in this external state store
now why is this hard to maintain this is
how to maintain it basically from two
from two observations you can actually
see a message one here is this offset
this offset infinim Kopke this offset
basically represents the progress in
your input to how far you have reached
in this streaming application and then
each record that is consumed will affect
what state is represented here right it
is hard to to really keep a consistent
view of this offset store and visit
Stearns state store and what is produced
in this cave is store because everything
is not handled to be consistent by the
staple stream processor but the user of
this stream processor needs to handle
this consistency here so things approach
to stable stream processing is really
internal State internal state so the the
mention here about sternal state was
basically what I mentioned is usually
much lower due to remote read and writes
against an external states or you could
say that foal tolerances and scalability
is left to that's external storage but
then the disadvantage is really this
remote read which would more or less
become this performance bottlenecks
sooner or later once your business
skills okay and it's not that easy to
get this exactly once guarantee which is
crucial for for if you want really if
you want this pipeline to be really
producing accurate results which will be
right relying on on your business so
internal state what this ready means is
okay each state each computation
instance has some notion of a local
state back end and each state read and
write each state access really goes to
this local state back end and what this
stream processor needs to do is really
handle foe tolerance of this local state
right and this is really handled by in
flink terms it is periodically
snapshotted to the stable storage and
this table storage is basically a
distribution can be HDFS can be s free
it can be as zeros it can be any any
faster or somewhat similar solution in
the cloud some cloud providers right now
have or it could be just any network
mounted filesystem anything that is
accessible throughout over computation
open nodes can serve as this stable
storage okay so so far so good
state internal state we have local
reason writes performance wise it is
superior to external state but the the
stateful stream processor then needs to
handle the process of periodic
snapshotting and restoring and
maintaining basically photons of the
state so how does Fling actually do that
we can because we can first consider a
very simple case of how how to do this
let's just consider the simple case of
just one process there's no distributed
environment but just one process
consuming one one queue of events what
we can do and
that here is says local state but it can
just be anything it could be just a
process and some in-memory data
structure in this process which has some
values which represents the state of
this computation so what is basically
done is for each record what you can do
is when you process each record you take
a snapshot and this snapshot includes
two things the first thing is the value
of that state variable right or whatever
is in the memory of data structure of
this process takes that sort of that as
well as the position in the queue that
it has processed so each state value
represents corresponds to a position in
the queue now as you process further
records if let's say a process to this
record and now the process fails for any
reason all you have to do is find the
last nap shot let's say this snapshot
represents position here and at that
point in time the state value was some
value now so it's really just replaying
that process and then resetting the
position of the queue and then starting
to replay from there using the scenario
in this very simple case then you can
actually achieve exactly once exactly
once guarantee but the interesting
question is how do we create consistent
snapshots of distributed embedded State
right or more importantly how do we do
it
efficiently without abrupt in
computation in the distributed center
scenario also have this Q and we have
this Q and when we have distributed
operators of streaming pipeline that is
basically all records a pipeline through
over operators in this daj okay so what
is done here as records our pipeline
through the consistent view of a
snapshot similar to the single process
scenario is we also need to have the
position in the queue but the state
corresponds to all the local states of
each operator okay so this is the
consistent snapshot now very
straightforward so if if some some code
some operator fails all we need to do is
because we periodically checkpoints all
these local states a long way
their position offset into the file
system and if anyone tells them just
restore everyone we role is basic like
every row operation similar to the
simple case but the question is how do
we do this efficiently but dumb way to
do this over simple ways to do this is
really just say okay for each record
consumed from let's say Kafka it has to
traverse through the whole tank before I
can let the second record the next
record go through a pipeline poop deck
now that's not good because we're
basically doing global stop on the
compensation for earlier operators to
actually generate this consistent SAP
shot so that's not good
so if link how this is done is it's
called a mechanic code distribute
snapshots and if you're familiar with
in-memory databases or come from a data
base area this is this is basically a
variant of a Shandy Lamport algorithm so
in flank these this is called a
synchronous checkpoint barrier so what
is essentially done is flink will inject
these special checkpoint barrier events
to be pipelined along with events and
they the chapman barriers cannot
override or the ordering cannot change
as soon as they're injected okay let's
see how this is actually used in in in
the framework so this is really used by
let's say we have a job here to conquer
partitions and we have as two sources
and two operators which have local state
here now let's say flink
says we need to inject a checkpoint
barrier we need to we need to take a
snapshot of the distributed pipeline
right now
what happens is this checkpoint barrier
is injected and then it flows along with
the following events into this next
operator now by the time by the time
this checkpoint barrier has arrived at
this operator has at this operator all
the events that were after this trip on
bear has been manipulated into the state
right it has been processed and has
changed the state so the state
corresponds to that position in the oven
in the checkpoint queue
and what this really does once the
operator receives his chuckling barrier
what it does is it triggers a state
snapshot now this is really just a very
small synchronous part where it does a
copy-on-write
operation what this copy-on-write
operation really does is so that the
copy of a state can be a synchronously
transmitted to the central TFS for
persistence but at the same time during
this transmitting which is a synchronous
processing can continue and to met him
manipulate the state without this state
of that previous checkpoint being
transmitted to be corrupted okay so that
copy and write operation is just so that
the synchronous part of this
snapshotting is very very small it's
very very lightweight the heavy part
which is actually for transmitting is a
synchronous and does not stop a
processing so this is really how link
and various there can be multiple
parallel checkpoints that are happening
forever pipeline I was just showing a
procedure of one specific checkpoint
happening cool this is even a bit more
detail about how this checkpoint aligns
let's skip this part because we actually
don't have too much time for this okay
so I just want to quickly show the
synchronous checkpointing part so if a
synchronous checkpointing is really just
this image is really just showing the
difference between synchronous try
pointing and a synchronous check
pointing if we don't have a synchronous
checkpointing implemented then when the
checkpoint barrier arrives at the
operator it basically uses the same
event processing thread where the event
processing thread is blocked - and this
red part here is really a part which is
the time taken to transmit to the DFS
but to have a synchronous check pointing
here this snapshotting part really is
just fairly small and as soon as the
synchronous part is ended then it just
starts continuing this event processing
and leaving the checkpoint thread to do
the transmission to the DFS and this is
all based on copy-on-write it's
implicitly an implementation of MVC
see and if you want to let that check
that out okay so up to now it's really
only about how flink snapshots take
these consistent snapshots consistently
and efficiently now it's about how does
flink handle large state so your state
can be arbitrarily large and users have
been reporting gigabytes or even
terrible levels of state within report
of where production jobs in companies
like Netflix uber lyft and even some
users which that I just recently learned
about in the Southeast Asia region for
example go check and and grab are also
using clink member in there in the
production pipelines at the moment um so
so how do we handle very large state
which goes beyond the memory size so
really state access in flank as I
mentioned your code word it really looks
like something like this where you
access the state each read and write
goes through an actual local state
back-end okay link right now has two
flavors of state backends by default you
would use the heap back-end which all
state moves in memory and Java heap and
readwrite basically operates on Java
objects and state size is essentially
bounded by the memory size or heap size
the other flavor in case your state is
operatory large which is mostly used for
reduction is rocks TV Beckett back-end
where your state actually lives and off
heap on on disk by the way the user
doesn't really see the difference is
really the user API it just feels like
accessing a local variable but it's just
going through these different flavors of
backends operator by species realization
so one performance hit already is this
is the serialization here so even though
peroxy be back-end can handle larger
state sizes but the disadvantage is
really if this civilization overhead
would affect the leaf Rupert so I think
benchmarking wise it's a ten times
difference but it comes with different
state size capacities of course so just
a very recap the heap back-end the way I
like to say it is it is lazy
civilization and eagerness realization
has
what it means is on every state access
for per record you would not go through
any Java sterilization any civilization
sorry this really just Java object
manipulation but when you actually
receive the check one barrier and want
to persist fair to the DFS when the
system persists each local states of a
DFS then civilization happens and when
you restore pup in DFS when you evilly
dis utilize adds in ut civilize
everything into objects already at
restore time for rocks TV it's the other
way around
ego civilization lazy dis realization so
I'm per record what happens is you need
to go through ad civilization
civilization round-trip on on each
records computation and then on
checkpointing on or restore what really
only happens is you could just think of
it as a dump or an exchange of state
white blobs okay and another part about
how flink handles large state is
something we called incremental
checkpoints so to understand this this
is an image this is a demonstration of
full checkpoints so what happens in full
checkpoints is that say you have
checkpoints at t1 t2 and t3 and the
state is ABCD at t1 t2 it is AF CDE
whatever and t3 vessels will never form
but on each checkpoint the whole
complete state is check pointed now if
your production job ready has the state
sizes as I mentioned 50 terrible 50
gigabytes or terabytes levels this would
be a problem right so we we were talk
about community apache fling community
was talking with companies on Netflix
uber and then we came up with this
incremental checkpoint concept which is
actually fairly straightforward to
understand so we have ABCD at t1 at t2
it's just fab red key has changed to a
value F a different value we have a new
different have a new TKE here so what we
want to do is from checkpoint one it
could be a full snapshot but for
following checkpoints is really just for
Delta the difference in what has changed
in the state and this
dramatically change dramatically reduces
the state size and needs to be
transferred to the DFS for each
checkpoint right and it also depends on
your use case in a state access pattern
but in most scenarios this works quite
well right now as I mentioned there's
two different flavors of state back and
sampling frame numbers heap and there's
rocks DB incremental checkpoint is only
implemented in rocks DB I can explain
why here rocks DB or let's say to be
more accurate osm trees is naturally
well suited for implementing incremental
checkpoints saint-roch CB here isn't
that accurate but in general osm trees
me proponent familiar with the data
structure are some trees that rock CBO
level DV uses within bar databases it's
somewhat like this so all your rights
goes into this in memory we can in
memory index which is generally called a
mem table amend table and once this mem
table reaches of certain size threshold
it is but the content of the mem table
is dumped into an SS table and this is
as SS table is really just you can think
of it as a sorted sorted files for the
index which is sorted by key so once
every new SS table is generated these SS
tables are continuously merged into
lower-level
SS tables and this merge is can be done
quite efficiently because every every SS
table file is sorted by key so when you
merge is really just a merge sort of
operation so the essence here of why
this is suitable for incremental
checkpoints is that because SS tables
are immutable so our SS tables as SS
tables are generated or deleted because
of compaction of LCLs LS entries the
difference of created and deleted as his
table files basically essentially
captures the V Delta of state here okay
so if link it basically uses this this
this this behavior to capture
incremental check points now for heap it
back end it is also similar it is also
possible to end
incremental checkpoints because the data
structures in the heat back-end already
support MVCC so the support is somewhat
possible to implement incremental
checkpoints and detection of a delta of
state there but since he backends are
generally used for small state sizes
having incremental checkpoints supported
there isn't really a higher priority of
a community out of the moment so that's
why only rocks TV implements incremental
checkpoints right now okay for the last
part I want to quickly talk about Kerbal
state it's not really a production-ready
feature yet in Flint but we're working
towards it
but I once quickly explain what is why
it is actually quite an exciting
exciting feature so if you haven't
noticed already by now the state within
flink is really essentially a coqui
partition started KB store right because
you've partition your stream so the same
key always goes to the same computation
instance and add that computation
instance the state public key is always
locally accumulated there so you're
basically also partitioning this january
state and by that key and let's say you
have a window operator a window operator
generating results per hour this the
state here within that window operator
basically represents two in-flight
aggregations right so let's say your
your scenario right now is you're trying
to generate a dashboard which shows the
historic allegations of each hour in the
past but at the very very last column
what it is showing is the in-flight
aggregation of a current minute or
whatever of a current min of a real-time
view basically in the past we would have
this lambda architecture which would
have the streaming layer and then the
match layer it would have a lot of
moving parts to actually just to be able
to generate such a view but using a
stable stream processor and so-called
miserable sate feature it can be
actually fairly straightforward so you
have this window operator which is
generating the hourly aggregates and
then storing them into the KB store but
if you want a real-time hot data hot
result what you basically needs to do
is just curry a state within this
operator to know what is the real
real-time in-flight aggregation okay
so using this curry service which
basically delegates this check this
curry to the KB store or to a in flight
state within flink this can serve that
dashboard we were talking about just now
okay I have a whole nother section for
outlooks for application architectures
so that was about stateful streaming
stream processing a fling and the
current state of things right now but
I'm also the opinion about how the
staple stream processor would fit in
micro services or application
architectures which I would love to talk
about if you are interested in and I
also have an office hour at 3:30 I think
so if you're interested feel free to
come and proach and we can discuss it
that's all for today thank you
[Applause]